streets that's going to come attack you  I own pepper spray okay but he's got a  knife  and I could get a taser you don't want a  man to protect you in the jungle out  there okay let's say I have like a  scrawny husband like how much is he  really gonna be able to protect me what  are you gonna pick a scrawny man no I'm  not exactly why aren't you gonna pick a  scrawny man because that's just not my  preference but like that is some  people's preference it's not some  people's preference all women want big  men that's not true I've met some  interesting women do you want to be a  CEO and a boss [ __ ] yes why  because I want to be able to make my own  money and provide for myself